This lecture is about the ordinal
logistic regression for sentiment
analysis.
So this is our problem set up for a
typical sentiment classification
problem, or more specifically, rating
prediction.
We have an opinionated text document D
as input an we want to generate as
output already in the range of one
through K, so it's discrete rating and
thus this is a categorization problem.
We have K categories here.
Now we can use a regular text for
categorization technique to solve this
problem, but such a solution would not
consider the order and dependency of
the categories.
Intuitively, the features that can
distinguish Category 2 from
1, or rather rating 2 from 1, may be
similar to those that can distinguish K
from K - 1.
For example, positive words generally
suggest a higher rating.
Now when we train categorisation
program by treating these categories as
independent, we would not capture this.
So what's the solution?
In general, we can add order to
classify and there are many different
approaches, and here we are going to
talk about one of them is called the
ordinal logistic regression.
Now let's first think about how we use
logistic regression for binary setting
categorization problem.
So suppose we just want to distinguish
it positive from negative and then it's
just a two category categorization
problem.
So the predictors are represented as X
and these are the features and there
are
M features altogether, which feature
value is a real number, and this can be
representation of a text document.
And y has two values, binary response
variable . 1 means X is positive, 0
means X is negative.
And then of course, this is a standard
two category categorization problem.
We can apply logistical regression.
You may recall that in logistic
regression we assume the log of
probability that Y is equal to 1 is
assumed to be a
linear function of these features as
shown here.
So this would allow us to also write
the probability of y = 1 given X in
this equation that you are seeing on
the bottom, and so that's logistical
function and you can see it relates
this probability to
probability that y = 1 to the feature
values.
And of course, B_i is our
parameters here.
So this is just a direct application of
logistical regression for binary
categorization.
What if we have multiple categories,
multiple levels?
We actually use such a binary logistic
regression program to solve this multi
level rating prediction.
And the idea is we can introduce
multiple binary classifiers and each
case we ask the classifier to predict
whether the rating is J or above all
the ratings lower than J.
So when Y_j is equal to 1, it
means rating is J or above.
When it's zero, that means the rating
is lower than J.
So basically, if we want to predict
rating in the range of one through K,
we first have one classifier to
distinguish K versus others.
And that's our classifier one, and then
we're going to have another classifier
to distinguish K - 1 from the rest.
That's classifier two, and in the end
we need a classifier to distinguish
two and one
So altogether we'll have K - 1
classifiers.
Now if we do that of course, then we
can also solve this problem, and the
logistical regression program would be
also very straightforward as you have
just seen on the previous slide.
Only that here we have more parameters
because for each classify we need a
different set of parameters.
So now the logistic regression
classifiers indexed by J, which
corresponds to a reading level.
And I have also used offer subject to
replace beta 0. And
this is to make the notation more
consistent with what we can show in the
ordinal logistic regression.
So anyway, so here we now have
basically K - 1 regular logistic
regression classifiers.
Each has its own set of parameters.
So now with this approach we can now do
rating prediction as follows.
After we have trained these K - 1
logistic regression classifiers,
separately of course,
then we can take a new instance and
then invoke
a classifier sequentially to make the
decision.
So first let's look at the classifier
that corresponds to level of rating K.
So this classifier will tell us whether
this object should have a rating of K
or above.
And if its probability according to
this logistical regression classifier
is larger than .5, we're going to say
yes, the rating is K.
Now, what if it's not as large as .5?
Well, that means the reading is below
K, right?
So now we need to invoke the next class
file, which tells us whether it's above
K - 1.
It's at least K - 1 and if the
probability is larger than .5 then will
say, well,
then it's K - 1.
What if it says no?
Well, that means the rating will be
even below K minus one, and so we're
going to just keep invoking these
classifiers until we hit the end.
When we need to decide whether it's two
or one, so this will help us solve the
problem, right?
So we can have a classifier that would
actually give us a prediction of rating
in the range of one through
K, unfortunately, such a strategy is
not the optimal way of solving this
problem, and specifically there are two
problems with this approach.
So these equations are the same as you
have seen before.
Now the first problem is that there are
just too many parameters.
There are many parameters.
Now can you count how many parameters we
have exactly here?
Now this may be interesting exercise.
To do so you might want to just pause
the video and try to figure out the
solution how many premises we have for
each classifier?
And how many classifiers do we have?
You can see the answer is that for each
classifier we have N + 1 parameters.
And we have K - 1 classifiers
altogether, so the total number of
premises (K - 1) * (M + 1).
That's alot alot of parameters.
So when the classifier has a lot of
parameters would in general need a lot
of data to actually help us training
data to help us decide the optimal
parameters of the this such a complex
model?
So that's not the idea.
The second problem is that these
problems these K - 1 classifiers are
not really independent.
These problems are actually dependent.
In general, words that are positive
would make the rating higher and for
any of these classifiers, for all these
classifiers.
So we should be able to take advantage
of this factor.
Now the idea of ordinal logistic
regression is precisely that
A key idea is just the improvement over
the K -1 independent logistical
regression classifiers, and that idea
is to tie these beta parameters and
that means we are going to assume the
Beta parameters these are the
parameters that indicate the influence
of those weights.
And we're going to assume these better
values are the same for all the K - 1
premise, and this just encodes our
intuition that positive words in
general would make a higher rating more
likely.
So this is intuitively appealing
assumption.
It's reasonable for our problem set up
when we have this order in these
categories.
Now, in fact, this would allow us to
have two positive benefit of one is
it's going to reduce the number of
parameters significantly.
And the other is to allow us to share
the training data, because all these
parameters are assumed to be equal.
So these training data for different
classifiers.
Can then be shared to help us set the
optimal value for beta.
So we have more data to help us choose
a good beta value.
So what's the consequence?
The formula would look very similar to
what you have seen before, only that
now the beta parameter has just one
index that correspond to the feature
and no longer has the other index that
corresponds to the level of rating.
So that means we tie them together and
there's only one set of beta values
for all the classifiers.
However, each classifiers there has a
distinct Alpha value, the Alpha
parameter, the except it's different
and this is of course needed to predict
the different levels of ratings.
So apha subject is different.
It depends on J.
Different J has a different alpha, but
the rest of the parameters of beta
are the same.
So now you can also ask the question,
how many parameters do we have now?
Again, that's an interesting question
to think about.
So if you think about it for a moment
and you will see now the plan that we
have far fewer parameters.
Specifically, we have N + K - 1
because we have M beta values and plus
K minus one alpha values.
So that's just the basically that's
basically the main idea of ordinal
logistic regression.
So now let's see how we can use such a
method to actually assign ratings.
It turns out that with this.
Idea of tying all the parameters,
the beta values,
we also end up having a simpler way to
make decisions, and more specifically
now the criteria whether the predicted
probabilities above is or at least .5
above and now is equivalent to whether
the score of the object that is.
Larger than or equal to negative of
alpha_j as shown here.
Now the scoring function now is just
taking linear combination of all the
features weighted by beta values.
So this means now we can simply make a
desicion of rating by looking at the
value of this scoring function and see
which bracket it falls into.
Now you can see the General Decision
rule is
thus when the score is in the
particular range of our values,
then we will assign the corresponding
rating to that text object.
So in sum, in this approach we're going
to score the object.
By using the features and the parameter
values, beta values.
And this score will then be compared
with a set of training the other values
to see which range the score is in, and
then using the range we can then decide
which rating the object should be
getting because these ranges of our
values correspond to the different
levels of ratings, and that's from the
way we train these other values.
Each is tied to some level of reading.